à contre-courant des chefs d'état de la
planète une voie pour le moins
singulière celle est celle de jaillir
ball sonar au le président brésilien
refuse de décréter le confinement dans
son pays fustigeant les gouverneurs et
maires qui décident de l'appliquer dans
leur région clément hospital c'est un
appel à l'aide sur les pare chocs de
leur bus scolaire
ces conducteurs de sao paulo réclament
l'aide du gouvernement pour faire face à
la crise économique qui gagne le pays en
même temps que celle du coronavirus mais
jaillard golden arrow pour qui le
cofidis 9 n'est qu'une grippette a
engagé un bras de fer contre la majorité
des gouverneurs du pays
ces derniers ont interdit les activités
commerciales et les services publics non
essentiels pour faire face au virus
spams ou spots ont traversé tous le pire
moment de la pandémie mais ça n'est pas
reconnue vue compris identifiés par tous
ceux qui se sont aveuglés par la haine
ou l'ambition personnelle hausse et
thomas les ouvrir à l'économie dès que
possible au bon moment de la bonne façon
et tout en respectant la science une
crise sanitaire devenu donc politique
à l'image de cette scène où le président
brésilien assiste à un rassemblement
contre les mesures de distance à sion
sociale ironie du sort jaillir ball
sonar au tous à plusieurs reprises lors
de son discours face aux protestataires
le brésil s'enfonce également dans une
crise sociale le coronavirus contribue à
creuser le fossé entre les brésiliens
aisés et les pauvres habitants dans des
favelas ce ici dans les rues de la
capitale économique sao paulo les
habitants les plus pauvres s'organisent
comme ils peuvent cette situation à
laquelle nous sommes confrontés
maintenant ne fait que souligner le
grand drame des inégalités il y avait un
message sur les réseaux sociaux qui
illustre cela nous ne pouvons pas dire
que tout le monde est dans le même
bateau
nous pouvons dire que nous évoluons dans
la même mère certains sont sur leur
yacht tandis que les autres nages notre
pire problème est le manque de logements
si nous avions une maison j'y resterai
pendant la quarantaine je ne serai pas
dans la rue le cornet les rues ce n'est
qu'un problème de plus auquel nous
sommes confrontés rester confinés chez
soi se laver les mains ou encore
utiliser un masque
autant de recommandations presque
impensable pour ceux qui vivent dans les
rues du pays
c'est un des jours à sao paulo 22 sans
abri serait mort du virus dans les rues
du poumon économique du brésil